Over time, humans have continually come up with new ways to communicate.
And while we've come pretty far,...
...there are still some things that don't quite work the way they should.
For instance, consider voicemail,...
...which you can only listen to by calling one number on your phone.
It is stuck in your voicemail system...
...and it deletes itself automatically after two weeks.
Or say, you're trying to reach a friend with a mobile phone, a work phone, and a home phone.
Right now, you might call each number one by one trying to find the person.
And after you finally leave a voicemail,...
...the guy has to call the right voicemail box to find your message.
So, we asked, "What if telephony were reinvented today?"
The result?
Google Voice.
Google Voice gives you lots of cool calling features,...
...no matter what kind of phone you have or which carrier you use.
For instance, if someone calls your Google Voice number,...
...you can have it ring all your phones or none of your phones...
...depending on the time of day or the person calling.
And if you let it go to voicemail, you can listen in before answering...
...or just wait and read a transcript of the message, and maybe send a text message reply for free.
And if you have an unwanted caller, it's easy to block them.
The list of features goes on and on, and keeps growing.
Point being, in short, less annoyances and more awesomeness for free!
So, give it a shot.
Visit google.com/voice.